have you been watching the mandalorian
no no actually i haven't i haven't i
haven't i'm trying to catch up with
films this year to vote for the baftas
and the oscars so
um i can't do a lot of the baftas
because fortunately we've been nominated
in the mauritanian so that's a little
plug there
but yeah no that's a way of saying i
haven't had much tv time and because i'm
making doctor strange
so sure yeah i've got that stored up
trees
why why what they're saying i was going
to say that there's a backhand there's a
lot of people that would like you to
play
a character called grand admiral thrawn
and i'm just curious if you've heard
people
saying this because he i could see you
playing this role
grand admiral thrawn does he turn into
peter cushing or something is that no
it's a he's blue he's a very cool
character
that's a villain that would you'd be
under
like a blue makeup thing anyway i'm just
curious if i think that's
that's a straight note for me right now
i there's nowhere i want to be
turned blue i could turn the air blue
very very recently but
no no seriously i i i i precious time
with my children and
uh i think sitting in a makeup show
being painted blue in the amount of time
it would take to do that and then take
it off the end of the day mike
might just it's not the right time in my
life for that